the super bowl is here
and in the super bowl is a team from los
angeles california
unbelievable run
by the los angeles rams to try and match
what the bucks did last year although
they've already kind of bettered it by
winning a home game
in the nfc championship game to make the
super bowl in los angeles happen for the
rams and the general manager of the nfc
champion los angeles rams less need back
here on the rich eisen show how are you
les
i'm good how about you rachel all right
great i was just asked by one of my guys
here about people blowing uh yup for
tickets or anything like that you you
must be do you have do you have do you
have a perimeter built around you
security perimeter built around you less
for this week you definitely need a
perimeter for sure it was it was
probably
uh perfect timing yesterday but it was
interesting for some reason my phone
did something and like so the contacts
weren't really
matching you know they weren't showing
up on my text so all i was getting was
these numbers yeah and you know there's
always the congratulations
right oh
no so you gotta be new phone who this is
that what you're going to be like last
night but
when i was a holy cow this is either
good or bad how do i handle it
but like like a lot of things in life
like you know probably took me longer
and more frustration than i should i
just actually
figured out how to turn it off and power
it off well done let it take a break and
then came back on the contacts were
there so
um
crisis yeah
uh you could you could definitely use a
let's call it a take a staff of
ticketers
if that's the word for the less just two
on the home side no big deal stop don't
worry
don't don't don't listen to him
he'll just go to the secondary ticket
market don't worry about that
don't do that
um so les let me just jump in here what
does a general manager of uh uh do
in the week leading up to a super bowl
like what is your job what is your role
less
right now you know that
there's no manual of that because it's
definitely hard to get to this game but
i think that
i think the best thing that that i can
do in this role
right is to help sean his coaches make
sure
we alleviate the distraction right of
the of the party that goes on the law
with the super bowl because at the end
of the day right i probably i know i
can't help him figure out how to score
points on the bengals or stop them uh
from scoring so uh we you know obviously
we have a personnel staff that's helping
them with their you know
you know
let's call it who's good who's bad who's
impactful who's not all all those things
that they're working together so and
also once we get through the initial hey
where are we at injury-wise what roster
moves do we have to make things like
that do we need to clean this thing up
for the super bowl you know my job's
really
to to right help do my part in making
sure
that group is not distracted and focused
on uh right the main thing and that's
competing for this world championship so
who may be on that who's on that radar
screen right now health-wise
right now for the rams for super bowl
56.
i think what we you know the interesting
thing what we have we have two weeks
here and
and tyler higby had an injury during the
game so the nice thing is we get two
weeks to try to get him back to the
integral part
taylor wrap has missed some time and so
you know he's on his way but there the
the roster management of it all too is
we you know we have
uh daryl henderson that is beginning to
get back to practice sebastian joseph
day and some of the some if you want to
call it the gm maneuvering with head
coaches hey do you actually activate
those to the to the roster or you keep
them on ir
and with that right comes deletions from
the roster which is always a hard thing
to do this time of year right if you're
gonna i mean you're gonna cut someone
the week of the super bowl things like
that but so you you really
sean and his group raheem
they game plan joe d his group in in
like what positions may be more valuable
do you go heavy tight in running back
things like that so a lot of those
little nuances that probably are boring
your listeners
no this is what i asked i mean this is
important stuff you know obviously for
the super bowl and then there's other
stuff going on
uh what can you say as we're sitting
here right now about your offensive
coordinator and uh how he looks in
purple i mean is that something that you
know about with kevin o'connor
right you know here's what i can say i i
think uh
uh
he'll look good in purple and i think if
if that comes to fruition uh
and i think i think the vikings are
getting a heck of a
uh head coach i think he's got some
unique experiences like being that
quarterback right drafted
by the patriots being in the meeting
room with tom brady josh mcmahon there's
some there's some unique
real unique experiences that not a lot
of head coaches can bring
right our offensive coordinators can
bring to
a team because only so many people get a
chance to play qb and then he was a
journeyman per se which was probably
a negative right when you're playing i
can't believe i'm a journeyman but if
you're gonna you're gonna become a long
time coach
right being able to bounce around to
different teams different coordinators
different way of doing things it it
allows it allows for your you know your
bag of tricks of like what you'd like to
do what you definitely not like to do
but for all the listeners in southern
california the interesting thing is
is if you if you know southern
california you kind of know the beach
communities like there's this kind of
like big deal when you're young this
thing called junior guards right it's
like the life it's almost like going to
camp with the lifeguards so i can say
there probably hasn't been a lot of
right nfl head coaches who wear purple
in minnesota who was a junior guard
back in the day i didn't know that
you're going deep down the roster here
of information
so uh so kevin o'connell is is it let's
just put it this way uh could wind up uh
somewhere else and it appears that he is
so uh
what what do you think of the fact that
that that your con your staff keeps
getting rated
year in and year out um including the
guy who's coaching against you
in this year's super bowl
again i think
it's a compliment
to the ecosystem here
uh so and obviously anytime it happens
we're we're very excited right there
that someone earned
an opportunity right and and
heck a 132 type opportunity and and and
there will be there there's been guys
and there will be
uh some that move on to be coordinators
now on the negative side of that riches
is
wow we gotta
i said it's on the positive side it's
always fun
uh it's always interesting to try to go
find right up-and-coming
difference making type
people to add to the ecosystem what
definitely uh gets exhausting at times
is is orientating them training them in
the way we do things so seems to be a
constant but at the end of the day right
it would be what we call a champagne
problem right because usually people
other teams only they like to
let's call it promote people from
successful programs so
that's that's the rose of the thorns
need general manager of the nfc champion
rams here on the rich eisen show uh does
it help though to know zach taylor for a
game like this and have shawn there and
you know him he knows him and
uh obviously you know what he's been
able to cook up but uh is that a benefit
do you think and actually x isn't owing
this super bowl 56
you know that that's a good question
and
i was listening that uh
interesting i was listening to
willie mcginnis last night and uh and
you know willie and they all love
belichick right but he he was arguing on
nfl network that zach had the upper hand
because he knew sean
and and i
i i forget who it was that asked people
would you ever say that about someone
who left belichick that they had the
upper hand but interesting listening to
the whys on that we all know willie now
was like no i would never say that one
of the people that upper hand on
belichick so that that but
what is interesting we definitely i
think there's benefits but i'm not sure
it moves the needle in any way because
they
there's a lot of similarities to right
what they do and and how we do things
but there's also definitely some uh
derivatives and differences
uh
but it's so that but it does make it
very intriguing match up as as sean and
zach and their staff begin to
you know you know design the the chess
match chess match against each other no
obviously you weren't going to be in the
mix for the number one overall pick in
the 2020 draft although with you you can
never tell i mean you know there's
there's no such thing as an
impossibility when you're pulling any
trade off or what have you is you have
proven less need but
uh what was your evaluation of burrow
coming out of lsu and now you're seeing
him just two years in standing in your
way for a ring and a lombardi
it's it's interesting because we weren't
going to be right in the mix at number
one and at that point
right we weren't really looking for a qb
so it would probably waste my time to do
a really deep dive on
on someone like joe burrow just because
when to try to figure out a quarterback
and get that right i mean it's almost
like you
you got to spend all your time on that
and then and get somebody else the rest
of the drafts that's that's an
exhausting process so what is
what is that process less because again
you're seeing burrow do what he's doing
and clearly you made that uh evaluation
of stafford have uh to go ahead and make
that maneuver and here they are both
super bowl quarterbacks so what what is
that evaluation that's so difficult to
make i'd love to i think there's no
evaluation
and i think what you have to do right is
you're trying to figure out staff for
being separate being one he's played in
that person situation right you see him
you see him do it against nfl players
nfl schemes right but
you know so his first contention you
know he can be a successful nfl
quarterback uh situation is can he come
here right help move the needle in terms
of wins and losses and going deep in in
the playoffs burroughs and college
players a little bit different because
you're seeing them against
you know college players and will it
translate to the nfl but i do know even
though i didn't do an exhaustive
uh
evaluation of joe lsu has a lot of
players their conference the sec has a
lot of players so
probably watched about every game
joe burrow had and and and what
what you what's interesting is he's
playing against a lot of nfl players
well
and he's got a lot of them on his team
but he definitely
the systems translated it was it was
college football wasn't totally a pro
system but they were asking him to to
make nfl type reads uh uh so
you could some of those emails like okay
i think joe burrows
really really got a got a chance and and
he was fun to watch and and felt like
that was a a really good bet i do
remember texting
zach taylor or maybe sean and i called
him and i forget how they finished the
year it did seem like it was a tough
loss but i remember us telling him you
know what you'll be glad you lost that
game you get to draft joe burrow and
life will get better down the road here
so yeah so now here you guys isn't that
amazing now here you guys are in the
super bowl uh against one another
uh less need here on the rich eisen show
and so
you know
obviously you saw something that
stafford could do it what made you think
he could do it and now you're in the
super bowl right now with him
les
what about that
i think i think
when you when we evaluated
right uh
matt yeah
the system fit he's the
he's he's one of the ideal qb's for
for sean because in shawn's offense
right it it's it is an element of
traditional pro-style uh
a little less of the college brent so so
matt had been doing that right heck not
only in detroit he did that at georgia
and he probably did that
in peewee football because in those days
there was really not a lot of spread
going on so he had had a lot of reps
that right right leading guiding
steering a pro style offense but i think
that
the thing you
immediately felt when you watch hey he
can make every throw he can make
decisions he can make them quickly uh
but when you really got to do a deep
dive in him you're like wow those are
you know those no look throws he would
make where he's manipulating maybe
linebackers at the second level safeties
at the third level and no looking over
here but because he just knows the
concepts of the d and how that would
just really throw them off you've got to
feel his his toughness of taking a hit
getting right up shaking it off the ol
you could tell the ol love blocking for
him because of that
and and it's like nothing happened and
you got to you also got to see those
those comebacks that a lot of a lot of
us didn't get to see because the lions
right didn't play prime time games or
things like that and
but that was definitely something on his
resume but to that's one thing
uh to see it to vet it but to partner
with him and live it and i think it came
to fruition right in the in the tampa
game right where you you see him be matt
stafford and and do all the things right
the defense play well and you got a 27-3
lead but you also see him be matt
stafford when holy cow how is this game
tied
and it's 42 seconds left and you know
what he had
he i like so whatever's in his dna to be
able to take snap and make a couple
throws clock it and
matt gay kicked the game winner and the
rest is history i think that that's when
you go holy cow that's that's special
yeah and then of course to have you know
the 69th overall pick third round of the
2017 nfl draft in cooper cup now be a
triple crown winning threat in an mvp
candidate of absolute note and total
bona fide threat right there aaron
donald may be being uh you know in the
discussion of greatest defensive player
ever a first-round draft choice by you
you know the additions of odell beckham
jr this year along with von miller made
everybody say well les it's all about
this year or nothing
and uh eric weddle my god he's now
playing like you can't take him off the
field he went from the couch to being
able to you can't take him off the field
and he's now a leader in the locker room
i know you got a super bowl to win
but what what is it like to be a general
manager pushing buttons and having them
work when everybody's wondering if you
can make it work less
well i i think
the the all ending i think there's i
think heck we were all in like a lot of
teams right we were all in probably when
we were building rich and and
and you're all in on the bill that's
that's where the
right we're probably doing an opposite
of what we're doing now we're trying to
collect
collect first round picks and and add as
much young talent as possible right to
grow together build a core and in in
your
you're trying to be intentional but
you're hoping that you're you break
through and we're fortunate enough to
break through and i think you know when
you do breakthrough if you're fortunate
there's your window what are you going
to do with it how are you going to take
advantage of it and i think
i think we
we've got a little bit of a philosophy
here where the hey the math says right
when you're trying to be one of 32 you
should probably be thinking a little bit
differently
right than the other 31 because it it's
a tight league
everyone's good you know
most organizations are highly competent
uh
so
that's kind of our philosophy but you
were fortunate enough to get in this
window and and we're going to try to do
everything possible to take advantage i
knew you wouldn't spike the football i
knew it but is it true little birdie
told me you got a standing ovation at a
local starbucks walking just merely
walking in this week is that a true
story less
is that true boy sometimes my wife's
twitter account
gets me in trouble right
but the uh you know the the answer is
yeah okay you okay yeah so you know okay
so you walk in you walk in and then
everybody starts breaking out and gives
you a a a venti of appreciation is that
basically what happened
you know it's kind of your core core
group but it was a little bit earlier so
it's the core core group
a lot of people who work at starbucks
right
i i'm okay talking about that rich
because there's been many mondays where
i've woken up said you know what not
doing coffee today
i can't i can't go face to music okay
you know
i'm gonna
i'm just gonna make it at home today
okay so uh all right you know that may
be the best thing about winning in the
nfl is when you get a chance to walk in
on a monday after a win
and get it and get a stanley starbucks
standing o um so i guess the last one
for you then less
harder hearts you know obviously you
know your roster inside and out as you
also know what might be uh exploitable
knowing again who is coming your way
boro chase uh knowing uh how
opportunistic this defense has been uh
in its playoff run what can what keeps
you up maybe when if you wake up middle
of the night staring at the ceiling i
got to talk to sean about this what what
do you think is is is
your super bowl 56 threat level
on that front with the bengals coming up
i think you know it always you know like
i mentioned earlier i try to stay out of
the way in terms of game planning
uh
that's that's not my area but at the end
of the day i think what we'll focus on
because when you whoever you're playing
this team's really good like you
mentioned they they've done a nice job
uh right
let's call it solidifying their their
eligibles
to
to uh you know let's call it catch the
ball run the ball all those things
around a dang fun qb to watch
like you said they got a lot of
veterans on that defense so that allows
them to it allows them to right hey
change their scheme right they'll scheme
according to and all similar to maybe
the patriots a little bit they adjust
quickly at half you can see you mean
obviously that was on display against
kansas city where it looks like it's
over they do some things at half next
thing you know they win the game so
anytime you play a game this magazine
that the opponent's good so i think what
we try to do internally here is is is
focus on
what we do best and then at that point
how does that translate into attacking
them
and and go out and and and compete and
try to be great when it matters and that
and that's all you you can do all right
because at this point in time when
you're playing for for one of 32 and
there's only two left
the opponent's going to be dang good
plus you what else you got to do right i
mean the senior bull you don't have to
ask anybody there you have no draft
choices left
right les who cares
right
you know that would be that would be uh
that would be uh let's call it
accentuating the the shallow narrative
that we
you know that we have the draft picks
you know we do we do have a we will have
a lot of picks they will all be
on day three but there's a chance we
have ten plus picks on day three okay as
you know unless um having known me for a
while and i've known you i'm an expert
at
accentuating the shallow narrative that
is what i do professionally so
um do it well you know
i'm the best dad
damn damn right i'm the best
entertaining content thank you sir and
anytime i start getting nuanced to the
second and third level of you know
compensatory formulas yes right you know
what i mean
your listeners love it i can tell you're
i'm losing you though
thank you less need i'll see you soon
we'll see you soon enjoy the week take
care man
there you go let's need everybody coffee
junkie
first team all hair first team all hair
general manager of the nfc champion rams
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here